all
right okay welcome to the ddps uh
seminar everyone before we introduce our
invited speakers let's go over some
rules and Logistics first of all please
mute yourself during the talk but if you
have questions uh you can unmute and ask
questions or use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A session at the end second today's
ddps seminar is open to external
audiences uh therefore no classified
discussion is allowed so please watch
out finally The Talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel all right that's about it let me
briefly introduce our speaker today it
is an honor to host Dr yesan Su who is
an assistant professor in the department
of computer science puru university the
goal of Dr Sue's research is to breach
large scale constraints based reasoning
with state-of-the-art machine learning
techniques to enable intelligent agents
to make optimal decisions in high
dimensional and uncertain real world
applications more specifically Dr Sue's
research focuses on scalable and
accurate probabilistic reasoning
techniques statistical modeling of data
and robust decision making under
uncertainty his work is motivated by key
problems across multiple scientific
domains ranging from artificial
intelligence machine learning renewable
energy Material Science crowd sourcing
citizen science Urban Computing ecology
to behavioral econometrics recently Dr
Sue has been focusing on developing
crosscutting computational methods with
an emphasis in the areas of
computational sustainability and Aid
driven scientific discoveries today Dr
Sue will talk about vertical reasoning
enhanced learning generation and
scientific discovery please enjoy and
expect a wonderful talk um now let me
ask a question to our speaker just to
get to know him know you better Dr Sue
and make this seminar somewhat informal
okay here it goes uh obviously you're
passionate about AI algorithm
development how did you get into the
world of AI
development how did I get into uh I
actually read a uh book uh about control
and Ai and uh it's actually from uh wher
uh it's a very old book uh and that's uh
you know actually dated back to uh you
know when they actually use this control
theory to uh you know to to expand uh
you know AI Behavior Uh you know human
behavior human intelligent Behavior Uh
and that was when I was a undergrad and
start learn about computer science and
uh so so I was fascinated about this
part and also you know with the robots
and so on that's amazing so yeah so
that's how I started um I guess you made
the right decision then yes uh I didn't
know that there will be this exciting
Shing
ahead of me uh for many years but uh
yeah awesome okay stage is yours okay uh
thank you very much thank you y for
great introduction and uh so I am Yan I
came from the Department computer
science at puu University uh today my
talk is going to be vertical reasoning
enhanced learning generation and
scientific discovery um so uh let me get
started uh so uh um you know machine
learning and automatic reasoning are two
fundamental pillars of artificial
intelligence uh and uh so you know a
little bit of history since we started
by talking about history of AI uh there
are these two group of people in
artificial intelligence uh one group is
the connectionists uh they develop
neuron networks and so on uh and uh you
know uh as you have been seeing uh that
the uh
you know a lot of recent approaches are
driven by this group of
connectionists but there are also uh you
know in AI another fundamental group of
people uh you know they uh believe that
you know intelligence can be described
using symbolic and logic based
approaches uh and uh so so this is
another group of people so AI has been
uh you know driven by the interplay of
these uh two group of uh
scientists uh now um you know in today's
world uh in today's world uh we can talk
about you know uh so the first group of
people they you know develop these uh
learning based approaches uh these are
botom up approaches which means uh you
learn predictive models from the data uh
and it is often very challenging uh to
provide formal guarantees uh for machine
learning uh models and learned models
May violate constraint
especially in real and unseen
situations uh on the other hand uh
automatic reasoning is another set of
very useful tools for AI this includes
uh you know mathematical uh programming
um satisfiability solving uh you know
comx programming and so on and so forth
uh so these are top down approaches uh
which means you build um uh you know
models from problem descriptions and
this often leads to region models uh
meaning that these formulations must be
agreed uh a priority uh and these kind
of um approaches are difficult to adap
to uh data
distributions um so uh my belief uh is
um you know to actually address the
Grand Challenge of AI we actually need
an integration of learning and reasoning
uh so I believe that uh you know we need
to marry these two approaches uh to make
a foundational uh progress uh now why do
I say that uh so here is a small example
so uh imagine you are a uh kitchen
remodeler and here is an existing
kitchen um and uh so um kitchen
environment uh and you have this
specifications of adding a blue
microwave right of the oven and adding a
green toaster left over oven and below
the sink um to accomplish this task
um you actually need first um you know
perceive where these existing objects
are um so this uh is a perception task
and um you know if we uh think about you
know how human brains um you know
accomplish this task uh is actually
accomplished by the so-called system one
uh perception system or uh the faster
sying system uh to actually locate uh
you know where uh these uh objects are
but uh this itself does not solve the
problem so uh if you really uh want to
uh you know add a blue microwave right
open and so on you actually need a
little bit of planning and generation uh
so this in terms of human beings uh are
accomplished by this slow thinking
cognitive system uh which is the system
to planning and generation system uh
that you actually reason about you know
where are these the locations of this
objects to be generated uh in relation
to existing objects uh and you also uh
will need to um uh you know uh reason
about what are the most reasonable
locations of this object to be generated
so typically for a toaster it does not
flow in the air it does not go to the
floor and so on and so forth um so this
step um you know for human beings are
accomplished by slow thinking uh but in
today's world uh if you think about how
you are going to uh you know if we use
AI uh terms um to describe this task the
first step is usually accomplished
because the perception step the first
step is usually accomplished by Machine
learning but then the second step uh is
um you know uh you actually need U
automatic reasoning to come into play uh
to accomplish this task so um you know
will a complete constraint reasoning
approach uh solve this task ask uh it is
actually very difficult uh the reason is
uh you know you do have a kitchen image
here and it's contains very um you know
full and Rich uh visual information uh
it is very difficult uh to actually
encode uh visual information in terms of
objective functions constraints and so
on uh so it's very difficult uh but we a
fully uh neural based uh neurod driven
uh you know machine learning approach
uh work uh so here I'm showing you a
image uh so this is actually generated
uh by one of the very popular uh
neurogenerative uh models approaches uh
it's called SL diffusion and it's
released last year um and when these
stable diffusion are given these
specifications and the existing kitchen
images uh it basically generates uh this
very busy kitchen uh it's
uh you know very uh looks great uh
contains a lot of uh appliances uh and
nice and cozy uh but at the same time uh
you know this uh kitchen basically
ignores uh the
specifications um we as uh you know as a
contrast we can generate uh these images
uh that satisfy uh user specifications
make minimal modifications to the
existing uh kitchen and add the same
time um you know look pleasing um so why
can we do that uh is actually by
embedding automatic reasoning in this uh
neurogeneration process uh so this is
our in general our three step um uh you
know pipeline in the first step uh we
have a perception module that's actually
uh locate uh you know where are these
existing objects then this has been uh
this gets f into the second uh you know
spatial reasoning module and this
spatial reasoning module it's a neuros
symbolic integrated uh module that
actually decides uh the locations of
these object to be
generated um so for this work uh we
describe the location of the objects to
be generated using bounding boxes and
basically this uh spal reasoning module
generates the co uh the coordinates uh
of these bounding boxes so what it does
is in one step uh it is going to uh
generate one coordinate and it's
generating the coordinates by halfing
the range of this coordinate until it
becomes sufficiently small so this is
accomplished by uh you know a recursive
neuronet that make these kind of
decisions step by step but then the
decisions made by the recursive neuronet
are filtered through a symbolic
reasoning engine uh to basically check
uh whether the uh decisions made by the
recursive neuronet violates U
specifications uh if it violates user
specifications um you know the uh the
symbolic reasoning engine will tell the
recursive neuronet to go the other way
uh around uh and then uh once these uh
you know bounding boxes are generated
they are filtered uh they are filled up
uh by the search stab a visual element
generator uh that actually um put uh the
um you know these B uh these appliances
uh that generates these appliances in
their uh you know locations uh so as
again I want to say that you know in
this approach we are able to uh you know
generate uh you know these kitchen
images that satisfy user specifications
but with the baselines uh cannot um so
uh in The Last 5 Years uh I have worked
on a diverse set of domains uh including
design generation language generation a
g scientific discovery and so on and so
forth uh there is a
consistent uh theme uh in my research
which is to uh integrate automatic
reasoning with machine learning uh so
today I am going to um you know use
three examples to show you uh that
reasoning can be used to enhance neural
generation uh uh can expedite uh
scientific discovery and solve uh
satisfiability module counting problems
uh integrating symbolic and statistical
AI uh with approval guarantees uh so
this is a rather long introduction and
also I talked about the first part of
the talk um so uh y do you think we
should take uh questions now or should
we um we can do that yes well I mean is
there any question from
audience you know I have one okay Pat um
yeah go ahead all thanks for the
introduction so I just want to remind
you and others that that um there's been
a lot of work on learning machine
learning with logical representations
that that does not require the kind of
extra steps you're going to talk about
and and I am fine with people who want
to integrate neural Nets with symbolic
reasoning that's fine it is not the only
game in town yes and I and and I and I
think so I just think you misrepresented
the field a little bit
okay uh I I you know uh I I think we can
take this uh uh you know discu uh you
know um more discussions at the end of
the talk um that I agree that are other
approaches um uh that uh you know
supplements neuro based uh approaches um
uh but you know the point I want to make
is uh you know uh end to end approaches
uh uh they will will have a difficult
time you know these end to endend neuro
based approaches uh they will have a
difficult time I agree with that yeah I
agree with that there are other
approaches I agree with you that there
are other approaches uh that uh that can
um you know uh that that can supplement
you know existing end to end approaches
uh for uh generation not not supplement
replace yes yeah in in some sense yes
okay all right um shall we move
on okay yeah yeah I can um yeah so so
the next part of the talk I'm going to
talk about you know reasoning experi
scientific discovery uh so uh there has
been very exciting progress uh in deep
learning uh and in scientific domains uh
it's equally exciting so um uh so know
AI has been used to drive scientific
discovery uh and this is a very good uh
picture uh because we actually yesterday
had the release of alpha F 3 uh so this
is a wonderful uh you know piece of AI
that can uh you know help us uh you know
identify the folding structures of
proteins uh so uh you know AI has been
uh used to make uh you know a tremendous
progress uh in uh uh in scientific
discovery as well uh however I'm still
arguing that uh human learning or human
scientific discovery still outp performs
um you know AI driven scientific
discovery so uh if you look at these
famous examples uh is of Newton Maxwell
Einstein and so on uh their Explorations
are driven by uh you know purposes uh
and they are able to learn from an
incredibly small set of surprising or
boring examples so if you look at um you
know Newton he's uh you know he is able
to figure out the law of universal
gravity uh by watching apples falling
from trees uh and the results of such
discoveries are interoperable elegant
models and uh equations that can be
applied to almost every corner of our
universe uh and this is um significantly
uh better uh than what uh at the moment
uh you know uh AI driven scientific
discoveries uh can uh achieve uh so a
question is uh what can AI learn from
Human
scientists uh to answer that question uh
we use symbolic regression uh this is
the task of learning symbolic
Expressions uh from experimental data as
uh a illustration uh so this is very
good benchmarks uh for scientific
discovery because if you think about uh
What uh Newton has been doing uh they
are really um uh you know discovered the
law of gravity this is a mathematical
equation uh from experimental data um so
there has been a lot of uh symbolic
regression approaches um so uh this is
my very crude uh summary uh so um so I
would say most of these uh approaches
follow the so-called uh horizontal paths
uh so I'm using uh this uh the discovery
of the law of um uh you know the ideal
gas law as an example um so what they do
uh is they start with a guas of ideal
gas law uh so because there are many
different equations of this type they
just you know pick up their first guas
and typically this is not a very good
gas uh so what they do is they start
involving uh this um you know the this
equation until they find a uh good fit
um so um so if you look at the trace uh
of the equations that they find along
the way uh this uh typically is a zigzag
pass um uh that they need to make a lot
of tries before they find the correct
equation now these kind of approaches
can be challenging uh because uh you
know simply because you know you have a
very big uh space and it's very
difficult uh to find the correct
equation
um so what we propose here uh is
following the uh vertical path uh and
this is actually coincides uh with the
scientific approach so what we do uh is
uh in the first step um uh you know we
hold all the variables uh as constants
uh and we uh carefully study uh two uh
the interplay of two uh uh variables and
we find so for example in this case uh
the pressure and volume they are inverse
proportion to each other uh and then
once we have this um you know uh reduced
the form equation uh we start to add
another uh you know independent variable
uh so in this case the number of gas
molecules and then another independent
variables and so on and so forth um so
um uh so this if you plot the trace of
the discovery it forms a um uh vertical
path uh from simple uh to large
equations uh and our argument is uh
research uh
in our arguments is this vertical
scientific discovery can supercharge U
uh you know existing methods in
discovering uh you know very complex
laws uh with many uh intering uh
scientific processes uh and uh vectors
uh this is because uh you know if you
look at the especially the first few
steps uh they discover these uh
equations in reduced spaces with subset
of variables uh that um uh a subset of
uh uh variables uh and uh because of
that the search spaces a lot smaller and
they usually is uh easier uh to discover
these reduced form equations and then
gets expanded uh to the four equation uh
just to prove my point uh this is a
human experiment uh so here is a table
uh and uh it's the the table is actually
generated uh by an equation uh by a
ground choose equation the input is X1
X2 and X3 and output is y uh so uh and
there's no no noise uh so if I don't uh
tell you the equation um so uh can you
uh see what the equation
is uh maybe this is
yeah it's a
X3 uh plus X1 X X1 * X2 yeah that's yeah
so you were um oh
thean okay um we can actually uh you
know just to uh help the um uh uh just
to help the rest of the audience uh to
actually figure out this equation uh we
can simplify the problem okay so uh so
uh if I ask you to look at uh these rows
uh it may be easier um to find this
equation um so um so let me stop here to
give um you know uh other people um a
little bit time to see um so so in this
case uh the equation is um uh you know
you can identify this equation um you
know the the the you know if you look at
this case it's you know this y = to X1 +
X3 okay so uh 2.5 + 9.5 is 12 1.8 plus
3.2 is 5 and so on and so forth okay um
uh and then uh you know what you can do
then is you look at these
rows um uh you can identify a similar
equation which is this x3 - X1 so 4 - 3
is 1 2.2 - 4.2 is -2 and so and so forth
um uh and then uh you know once you fe
uh once you see that the red uh rows uh
corresponds to um you know uh this X1
times uh plus X3 and the blue row
corresponds to minus X1 plus X3 uh and
then you realize that this X2 is 1.0 in
the red case and minus 1.0 in the blue
case so you look at these two equations
uh so here you have 1 * X1 and then here
you have min-1 * X1 and then it happens
to be that uh you know the red row is
1.0 the X2 is held as 1.0 and then in
the blue Row the X2 is held as minus 1.0
and so uh you know a a um candidate
equation maybe is X1 * X2 plus X3 and
that is uh indeed uh you know yon's U
equation and that is indeed the ground
TR equation uh so Y is very smart uh in
identifying this
equation got it yeah yeah some somebody
else also get it it's amazing so um so
um why can we do this uh is actually
because um uh you know uh we did this
control variable experiments uh you know
we first hold this X2 as 1.0 in the red
case and then we hold uh this X2 as
minus 1. in the blue case uh and because
uh you know you are you know doing these
control
experiments um uh you know uh when this
x2s are held as constants you can take
uh this uh variable out of the picture
and then it becomes a regression task of
you know X1 and X3 to Y uh and that
simplified uh the symbolic uh regression
uh
task um so our approach uh is basically
uh an implementation of this idea using
AI so what we do uh is in the first step
uh we hold all the variables uh as
constant and only allow one variable to
vary so in this case uh we allow uh you
know X1 to vary uh and then uh you know
we study it effect on the out the
dependence variable Y and we use genetic
programming uh to find an equation that
Maps this single input X1 uh to the
output y
um now because uh you know uh there is
only one input uh the search space um of
possible equations involving one
independent variables are not that many
compared to four variables um we use
genetic programming to map uh the single
input to the
output um and um you know because the
search space is not that big uh usually
genetic programming can find uh the
correct equation uh this has been
expanded in the second step to include
the second input variable X2 uh and then
we uh do is we ask genetic programming
to actually um you know expand uh from
the equations discovered in the first
step into a new equation that involves
both uh X1 and X2 uh now because the uh
you know the extension involves one more
variable at a time uh you know usually
it's a small modification to the
existing equation and in in this case
you know usually genetic programming can
identify the second equation involving
two variables uh and then this gets
being uh expanded to the third step uh
with uh three variables and then with uh
all the variables uh now I do want to
say that you know we happen to use
genetic programming uh as an approach uh
to find these intermediate equations uh
but uh we don't have to stick to this uh
uh you know approach um you know uh
later on we have tried other approaches
uh including you know right now the
Dominate approaches based on policy
optimization of deep reinforcement
learning uh and those approaches uh work
even better uh all I want to say is uh
this idea of expands from simple to uh
more complicated equations uh they can
uh uh you know they can supercharge
existing methods in finding uh you know
complex equations with many independent
variables uh experimental results uh
demonstrate
find um the pet recommended you to
explain generic program mean to others
in case there are some people who are
not familiar with with it oh oh genetic
programming maintains a poll of
candidated
equations uh and then uh they use um you
know they they they use mating uh and uh
uh it's uh they they mutating and
mating operations uh to actually improve
the you know these equations so that
these equations can fit better to the
data and this works naturally uh with uh
these kind of approaches because uh you
know so if you look at the first change
of this step is actually uh you know
expanding uh this equations involving uh
you know uh second uh variable and this
can be accomplished by mutating uh the
equations uh or mating the equations
with uh you know uh some other uh uh
equations what we are doing here uh is
uh we uh freeze uh you know part of this
equation discovered in the first step
and we only allow genetic programming to
mutate and M uh on these um uh on these
uh constants um uh that we find in the
first step that you know when you hold
these variables as different values uh
in the first step you will actually
realize that you know the fitted
constant values of this equation in
different controlled V values of this X2
X3 and X4 uh you know these fitted
constants will change so this is a good
suggestion of you know these particular
constants is actually represent a sub
equation uh and so uh we actually use uh
that can be uh you know leveraged by
genetic programming uh that's the Gen
program in the Second Step they only
expand uh on these uh you know this
these constants uh that are uh sub uh
sub equations uh and this gets expanded
again and again to the uh to the four
equations um hopefully that's um one
10,000 level uh 10,000 ft level
introduction uh to uh genetic
programming um so uh you know
experimental results show that uh you
know we can find equations with smallest
three errors uh compelled to genetic
programming and other approaches uh
based on deep uh reinforcement learning
um and uh this approach uh actually uh
is um you know closely related uh to a
set of approaches um I actually um note
about uh these approaches after I
discovered um you know our vertical uh
symbolic requestor uh the these uh
approaches are actually his historically
uh these bacon are dis uh are discovered
by Pat longle Uh starting quite early in
1970s uh and these uh systems are used
to discover empirical laws um and what
they do is uh they follow similar ideas
that they represent um uh you know they
represent information at a varying level
of descriptions uh with higher level of
descriptions summarizing uh you know the
equations discovered at lower levels and
they uh you know uh this bacon applies
data driven characteristics to detect
regularities in numeric and nominal uh
data uh and uh a very high level 10,000
ft level description uh you know uh
introduction to bacon is so let's use
the discovery of Ideal Gast as an
example uh so uh similarly as what uh we
do uh is um you know the bacon first uh
discovers uh you know the relationship
between pressure and volume uh when
holding you know other uh variables the
temperature uh the number of gas
molecules and so on as constants so
first it's uh you know discover that uh
you know these two variables are uh you
know the the multiplication is a
constant and so on and this gets be uh
you know summarized into a new variable
so in this case uh it's this variable of
K
uh and the the summarized the variable K
in the second layer is going to you know
uh they can try to find the regularities
of this new newly discovered variable K
uh with additional uh variables so in
this case uh is the temperature uh they
discover that you know this K is um you
know proportional to the temperature uh
and then uh this gets being summarized
again into another new variable so in
this case uh the variable B and then uh
these B are being uh you know added into
the system and then uh we discover the
regularities that this B also uh is
proportional to the number of gas
molecule n uh and then this basically is
also a recursive process and in the end
uh you know bacon discover uh this uh
particular um uh you know uh symbolic
form but then if you substitute uh you
know the you know B is actually k / by T
and then um you know K is actually P * V
you get the ideal gas law uh so this has
been a series of very successful
approaches um so if you look at uh you
know uh how how much data this is
required uh to discover uh you know the
ideal gas law U for uh Bon uh you
actually to discover this U the you know
this equation B uh equals to R * n you
actually need to vary uh you know the uh
all the value uh varies um all the
values of temperature T and then to
discover the um you know uh this uh this
equation k / by T is B you actually need
to vary all the different relationships
of P * D um so basically uh bacon
actually assumed the you know complete
factorial experimental design uh meaning
that uh you B basically need to um uh
you know uh you know you you basically
will need to uh you know go through all
the experimental conditions uh to um uh
you know uh find uh this um uh uh you
know the the idea of gas law uh our
approach is closely related to bacon uh
we uh actually is slightly different uh
so we always uh you know we treat this
as a predi task so we uh you know in the
first First Step um you know we try to
uh you know we select one variable as
the dependent variable and other
variables as independent variables and
in the first step we again similar as
bacon we U you know set all the
variables as constants and allow one
variable to vary uh so we discover this
reduced form equation and then in the
second step we expand uh this um you
know uh constants into a new constant uh
into a sub equation that involves
temperature and then in the next step uh
you know these um you know Sub sub
Expressions get being expanded again uh
with uh you know the number of gas
molecules and so on and the temperature
and this uh you know give us the ideal
gas law so it's clear uh it's um uh
clearly uh you know closely related to
bacon uh but uh you know because we are
assuming uh this uh you know uh the
intermediate uh form of the equations uh
in intermediate steps uh what we can do
here is uh you know we can actually um
uh you know speed up the process a
little bit uh that we do not need a
complete uh factorial design so uh if
you actually would like to uh figure out
you know what is the correct uh values
of the C2 uh you actually um uh only
need to uh you know if you are committed
to this uh the first uh uh you know uh
form of this R reduced form equation in
the Second Step uh you can uh you know
uh use um only a subset of the uh you
know the uh the controlled conditions of
this temperature to actually uh you know
figure out this second step equation and
so on and so forth uh so it's a little
bit more um you know efficient um so uh
we also show that uh you know our
approach
can speed up the discovery of partial
differential equations uh from um
uh discover of partial differential
equations from experimental data for
that uh we look into uh you know
learning uh models for dtic
solidification so this uh is described
by this uh very complex set of partial
differential equations and for this
experiments we uh only are interested uh
in learning the uh the values of of
these parameters uh and uh the form we
are still working on building an AI um
that can automatically discover this
form of partial differential equations
um so uh we consider the vertical
learning experiment uh in which we split
the uh these variables into two groups
the the blue variables and the red uh
variables uh we first defeat uh the
models uh with the data in which uh the
blue parameters they do not have effect
on the spatial temporal Dynamics uh of
this uh on of this model this allow the
uh the model to learn the Red parameters
uh at first and then in the second step
we allow the model to learn from the
data in which both the blue and the Red
parameters they have you know on those
data in which both the blue and red
parameters they both play roles um so uh
so this is the the simulation of the
ground Tru model if you learn all the
par at once uh you basically are able to
uh you know you're basically learning
this um it's a solidification process
but uh it actually you know learn these
um models with the round number of U uh
this snowflake with the wrong number of
pedals uh and if you follow the vertical
learning experiments you are able to
discover uh the ground Tru model that
actually simulates a
snowflake um so I talked about the
vertical symbolic regression this is the
idea of building from intermediate uh
symbolic equation to the four symbolic
equations uh we show that this vertical
uh Discovery uh also expedites learning
partial differential equations from data
[Music]
um that yes all the snowflakes are
unique I agree with you uh what we are
considering here is we can if we can
identify the um uh you know the the
exact condition
uh that form a particular snowflake uh
and that is really a very difficult task
um and we show that you know this
vertical Discovery can uh you know
discover uh you know uh the exact
conditions for forming that particular
snowflake um now I really want to say is
uh you know traditionally um uh you know
symbolic regression has been a uh pure
learning task uh so the input is data
the output is a model although the model
is in the form of mathematical equations
but still there are models uh because of
that uh this has been treated as a pure
learning task so most of the symbolic
regressors uh they they work with fixed
data sets um so what we believe is we
can bring automatic reasoning into play
uh and the reasoning is really to uh
reason about what are the uh you know
intermediate um you know uh hypoth es uh
models hypthesis uh and the experiments
that can work as stepping stones uh for
us to grow from uh you know these uh
small equations uh to intermediate
equation to the four equations and we
believe that you know by incorporating
automatic reasoning into learning uh we
can close this Loop uh and experti AI
juban scientific discovery uh process
even
more so uh that is the uh second part uh
of the talk
um uh I don't know if I we have
questions uh I I see many uh comments
flowing by but that was very quick I
cannot follow
up do do you want to um give the button
to the audience so that they can ask
question oh I can I can give a button to
the audience how can do that um well
it's it's mainly from pet but it's open
to any audiences but
um no I'm not this is all great thank
you for reviewing that and talking about
the
relationship I just have a few comments
that people can read I think you're
under selling it I think that your your
your approach is is uh more powerful
than your your in your in your paper um
that that you're turning this into a
that this is an was an exponential
problem you're turning it into a
polinomial problem it's a big
change
cool all right um anyone else from
audience if not let's let's move on okay
so uh so the third part is uh vertical
reasoning solving SED value from module
counting problems integrating symbolic
and statistical AI with Pro
guarantees and so for that I'm going to
talk about how we actually discuss this
okay so uh in 2020 uh during the
pandemic we actually discovered that
automatic reasoning enables learning
with proval guarantees uh so for that we
work with Mark random field models uh so
these are highly influential
problemistic models with a lot of
applications in computer vision natural
language processing bioinformatics and
so on and so forth um and if you look at
you know the paper condition random
Fields uh it has been cited to date over
18,000
citations so these are very widely used
um you know models uh and in fact you
know p and I were discussing Mar of
logic Network um Marco logic network is
a you know it can be interpreted as a
form of M random field um so um however
the probalistic inference and learning
for M random field uh is intractable so
uh you actually need to solve so this is
the uh the task of finding the maximum
likelihood estimation for bu random
Fields it actually has this um you know
the computation of the partition
function uh embedded uh in the U Global
mle estimation so this makes the problem
uh highly uh intractable uh we proposed
the first algorithm that converges in
linear speed towards the global uh
maximum likelihood estimation um so um
don't misunderstand here there is an
astronoid here here uh which really says
you know we didn't invent a linear
algorithm that can find mle for Mar
random field it's a stochastic gra
descent type of algorithm but in every
stochastic grin descent step we have to
solve MP complete problems uh so this is
still expansive uh but uh but still uh
you know we are the first uh algorithm
that can reduce this highly intractable
problem that is beyond MP comple comp uh
completeness
uh using uh uh using MP complete solver
set solver uh and while at the same time
gets approval guarantees uh
on maximum likelihood
estimations uh we also show that uh you
know we can work on this stochastic
optimization problem this is uh to find
you know policy interventions that
maximizes or minimizes the stochastic
function as you can see that this
problem also has probalistic influence
uh this um you know sum over and
exponential many scenarios embedded in
the global optimization and also make
the problem highly intractable uh we
again find the first algorithm that has
linear convergence rate for the global
optimal of stochastic optimization uh
for solving leader follower games uh
this is in Game Theory uh so we have
these kind of games in which you have
leaders committing strategy before the
followers uh and these are you know very
important games uh that enables many uh
applications in for social good and in
computational sustainability we consider
the quantum response games in which both
the leader and followers they uh act
probalistic uh they have exponential
large action spaces and this leads to
you know exponential size mixing
programming and also are highly
intractable we came up with the first
algorism that converges in linear speed
towards the true stock equivalent uh
again know we are the only algorithm
that can reason about uh the optimality
of the solutions we get uh since then we
asked the question you know uh uh you
know what are these um you know do these
problems have in common uh we realize
that all these problems are needs a
integration of symbolic and statistical
AI uh basically uh these kind of
problems all these problems can be
solved if you have a sess over that can
reason about uh probabilities so uh if
you uh so because of that uh you know we
propos this satisfiability module
counting problem this is a new language
uh that basically give the S solers um
this new module Theory uh to do
probalistic
inference uh so a satisfiability module
counting problem decid the choose of
bullying formula uh that involves uh you
know certain predicates whose uh values
are determined by probabilistic inflence
so weighted model counting is basically
another name uh for probalistic
inference and that's why we call this um
uh you know certifi ability module
counting problem um now what does a uh
SMC problem look like so here is an
example find me a hotel so my expected
working time to trle Ai and to either
one of the two cafes is no more than 30
minutes uh so to solve this problem you
actually need to have problemistic
inference so the computation of these
expectations uh embedded in a set
formula so you need to connect uh these
expectations uh with n and O Okay uh and
so so so that is why this make this
problem highly intractable uh and to
compu the expectation you have to do
probalistic inference which you need to
reason about uh you know the uh you know
the uh you know you need to reason about
random uh scenarios and this often leads
to these model counting problems which
are those you know gigantic sum that you
have been seeing uh now if you uh
rearrange the terms a little bit and use
indicator variables and so on uh then
you can actually write the problems into
the symbolic uh part of the problem and
the statistical part of the problem so
basically these kind of problems are uh
basically you want to find the solution
to a set formula uh in which you have
the uh the value of certain set V uh
booing variables determined by
probalistic inverse uh and that is
indeed uh the problems that we are
solving uh for the paper that we uh
published we consider this relax version
of the problem in which you have the
bidirectional implication replaced by
this one directional implication uh but
still for all applicational problem that
could consider all of these problems can
be uh you know written uh in this form
in this relaxed form
uh our approach is quite interesting so
the approach is we first uh you know
transform we first reduce this uh highly
intractable satisfiability module
counting problem into a set problem okay
so we first is a rewriting stat that
produce a set formula and then we use
the standard set solver to determine
whether the set formula is satisfiable
or not uh we can show that uh if the
original SMC problem is satisfiable if
you tighten the probabilistic uh
argument by a multiplicative constant 2
to the c um the original SMC formula is
still
satisfiable then our approach this
actual SMC approach can with high
probability uh find the satisfiable
solution on the other hand if the
original formula is not satisfiable even
if you relx the uh probalistic counting
argument by multiplicated
constant uh our XR SMC formula will
highly likely return that the original
formula is not satisfiable so uh we are
as far as I know uh the only approach
that can produce that can give you uh
you know uh approval guarantees height
approval guarantees So within a
multiplicative constant on both sides um
no other approaches uh can uh give this
kind of
guarantees um so why can we do that uh
we actually leverage a uh connection
between model counting and St solving
with randomized XO constraints uh so to
do that we actually consider this
unweighted problem that is really you
know to count the number of solutions to
a s formula but uh probalistic inference
is a weighted version of this uh this
problem and there are ways to reduce
weighted U you know probalistic
inference into this unweighted version
uh that I'm not going to talk about that
here so if you consider this uh
relatively simple formula um it has
these two uh models these two solutions
uh but that this is not interesting what
make it interesting is uh if you write
all the XO constraint uh that involve
these two variables XY and
X2 uh and then you testify whether each
of these models satisfy the XO
constraint or not
if it satisfy it is a one okay if it
doesn't satisfy it's a zero what you can
find here is every row has exactly half
of them are ones and half of them are
zeros okay uh now why is that
interesting is because suppose you
randomly sample an X all constraints
from the set of constraints and then you
pick up a model and you ask whether my
random sampled XO constraint whether
this model satisfy my randomly sampled
XO constraint or not you get a 50 50% of
the chance that that XO constraint this
model satisfy the XO constraint right or
to put it in another way if you have
this uh boing formula and you add to
this booing formula you conjunct to this
boing formula an actual constraint that
is randomly sampled from this said um
you will have a 5050 uh so
basically uh the 50% of the models of
the original bullying formula will be
filtered out by this uh randomly sampled
XO constraint in expectation okay so in
expectation the number of uh models that
satisfy this formula is roughly half of
the number of models that satify the
original booing formula okay uh now why
is that an interesting fact is suppose
you want to count if the number of uh
Solutions is more than 2 to the three
okay so here I'm using the red dos to
mean the models and you want to count if
there are more than two to the three
eight uh red dots okay what you can do
is you can start adding to the original
buling formula this XO constraint you
know that adding one XO constraint you
are getting rid of half of the red dots
okay
you can do this three times then what
you can do is suppose in the end you
know you have a red dot left in the last
step then you basically know that in the
second to the last step you have roughly
like two red dots and then in this step
you have basically like four red dots
and in the beginning you have roughly
eight red dots okay so you know that if
you have red dots left in the end highly
likely in the beginning mean you have
roughly more than uh eight Red Dot on
the other hand if you start with less
than fewer than eight red dots after
three filtering highly likely you won't
have red dots left okay uh now how can
you decide whether you have a left Red
Dot or not in the last step you just
basically test the satisfiability status
of this formula on the left okay uh now
why is that useful is because uh you
know in the beginning you have this uh
SMC problem that you have this
intractable model counting embedded in
the problem and this problem is highly
intractable uh but you can actually
replace this model counting with this uh
uh bullying formula as I talked about
that's involving randomly sampled xual
constraint this will change the whole
problem from this SMC problem into a
single set problem uh and at the same
time uh give you probable approximation
guarantees
uh so experimental results confirm that
our approaches outperforms uh baselines
in terms of solution quality this is
expected uh
because uh you know we have proval
guarantees but it has also outperforms
the existing approaches in time uh this
is uh really because of the uh you know
the tremendous progress made by S
solving uh in the last decade uh this is
another um uh you know uh this is
another uh uh applicational domain uh so
to conclude I talked about vertical
reasoning enhance the neurogeneration
vertical reasoning expedite scientific
discovery and vertical reasoning solving
s uh satisi modu counting problems with
guarantees uh what I really want to talk
about is uh both human beings human
brains and uh AI agents they need both
automatic reasoning and learning uh to
to to to to work uh and uh reasoning
and learning integrated together they
can multiply the power of them alone
last year there has been this famous
code uh is actually coming from one of
the you know Yano one of the
connectionists uh that's pointing out
that large language models one of the
limitations of large language models is
it cannot reason so large language
models cannot reason uh since then we
have seen that you know uh there are
these tremendous effort
trying to bring you know coding
interface web interface and all kinds of
tools uh into large language models uh
which in my uh interpretation this is
trying to add uh you know a certain
level of reasoning capabilities uh into
large language models which I believe uh
this is a very good start um but uh as
you see that I believe that you know the
Deep integration of reasoning and
learning uh they offer way more uh so uh
you know as you have seen in this three
examples reasoning generates design
satisfying uh user specifications
expertise learning with in scientific
discovery and solve satisfi modu
counting problems with con information
guarantees uh so I believe uh you know
this is going to be a very important
domain uh especially with the huge
success uh achieved by uh the large
language model
uh and this will touch based on a lot of
applicational domains um you know
ranging from you know Neer generation
scientific discoveries and so on and so
forth and I certainly believe uh that
this will be very important uh and one
of the most important driving factors uh
for AI uh in the years to come uh so
with that I'm going to stop here and
take questions thank you so much was for
the wonderful talk uh yes um as usual um
yes let's have a Q&A sessions any
question from audience or comments from
audience I'm my question is I'm my main
uh question is how does it scills um
computational and as the data
increases um obviously you have to train
this
one uh yeah so uh I um so uh I don't
know which I don't know which
application you are referring to uh but
uh um you know let's um so so there is
uh this um argument uh that recently you
know there is also an argument uh that
is in general about uh you know
embedding this reasoning into uh uh you
know neuro you know embed embedding you
know symbolic approaches into neuro
approaches and so on there is recently
these argument that uh you know you know
we the better stay with this uh you know
these neuro architectures uh recently uh
because uh because they can be
implemented in gpus um and that help
with scale with very large data sets and
and so forth uh which I think is very
important uh you know to actually build
these architectures uh that can work
very nicely with gpus that can be highly
paralyzable and so on and so forth um
however uh I um I I I still believe that
uh you know uh we shouldn't be stuck uh
into the current
computational uh framework um that GPU
probably is not the last stop of the you
know the computation uh framework and
you can see that um you know the um you
know even for uh you know these kind of
approaches uh that we add a little bit
of uh the reasoning so for the the the
three examples that I presented
today uh you know they currently they
cannot be you know solved end to endend
on gpus um so
even with that you know without you know
highly paral parallelism you can see
very big Delta right you can see uh you
know uh you know this really brings a
benefit that um I believe scale is not
able to bring um so so you know
my prediction is you know in the in the
future uh we would like to see this kind
of alter reasoning uh you know being
incorporated into this GPU friendly you
know this so that it can be scaled um
but uh we don't stop there we don't say
oh you know
any uh you know approaches that cannot
be that cannot scale up you know fully
by end to end approaches uh we just stop
exploring them uh I think that is a
wrong message um yeah but but I agree
with you that you know um uh I agree
with you that you know scaling is very
important yeah okay thank you um Pat do
you want to unmute yourself and ask your
question sure so of course I I really
like the second half of your talk part
of your talk um but not all scientific
fields are experimental right there's
Fields like ecology yeah astronomy
sociology that where all you can do is
observe the question is whether there's
any way to adapt your ideas your
approach to uh to deal with those kinds
of domains for example can you use
statistical analyses to do get the same
effect as experimental control in those
cases you have any thoughts on that I
have many thoughts on that I think uh
these are very important uh questions uh
and I think you know these domain
experts they are
way smarter than us uh you know they
they have been working in this domain I
was talking to an economists uh before
and you know part of the reason is you
know part of the the the headache they
have is they do not they cannot wrong
large scale experiments and so on uh so
they really needed to uh you know reason
about do this C counterfactual reasoning
about what may happen uh if the economic
a policy is in this way in that way um
by uh you know try to do that kind of
predictions from historical data uh in
which uh they don't have they didn't
have the policy implemented in those
ways so they really have to do a
statistical inference they really have
to do this counterfactual inference on
what might
happen suppose the uh you know the
policiy in those ways and so on uh and I
think that is
uh you know another domain that uh that
I think uh you know the third uh you
know if you look at the third part of my
talk is about use statistical reasoning
to prove a certain effect to to uh you
know to uh to give uh you know bonds
approval bonds for certain statistical
events and I think that is a very you
know that is something that's uh you
know very much worse r look into and um
but my specific question was whether you
could use the
vertical idea in non-experimental
domains that's what's not clear to me
and I and and and I have thoughts on it
too we can talk take it offline I just
wanted to raise the issue yeah I think
we we we should we should talk that on
offline and and uh you know I I also
have some some some idea there uh in
terms of so basically you know the these
kind of uh domains they have you know uh
process is in come in different scales
so we may be able to exploit uh some of
those uh to uh to to uh you know to to
make discoveries in those domains um
yeah um a longer
discussion all
right
um qu do you want to ask questions you
can unmute
yourself sure uh just wondering how well
the vertical symbolic reasoning uh
performs in a noisy environment such as
measurement noise in the independent
variables of your uh ideal gas law
example um are uncertainty
quantification methods um applied or
something
else uh yes so uh the V the noise is
indeed uh will affect the performance uh
of these kind of approaches um we have
um you know conducted experiments in
noisy settings uh and we find in that
case still vertical Discovery uh leads
in terms of speed uh then you know
traditional approaches uh in finding
symbolic laws um now um now of course if
you have a you know very large noise uh
that is going to affect uh and indeed
that is a problem that we are
investigating uh now um
I think what we have been seeing uh from
the um uh from the empirical experiments
that uh we conducted is typically we can
you know there are um you know models
that performs uh very well there are
equations that intermediate equations
that's um that that that leads to other
of magnitudes smaller you know
regression errors and those uh equations
typically correspond to the the correct
equation the gr Chu equation uh even in
the noisy settings so um uh so yes no
it's going to make things more difficult
it's going to make you know the task
more challenging uh but uh uh uh you
know as far as the experimental uh the
experiments we con uh conducted uh still
we can see that the vertical Discovery
is leading the other approaches in the
noisy
settings thank you
thank you thank you so much um any other
question from
audience I got one last one unless
unless someone else has so
so there are really two types of
experimental science uh the kind you
described and that I worked on um but
Fields like but but as science as
scientific discipline matures things
tend to become more hypothesis driven
and the experiments are designed mind M
to test to distinguish between
alternative competing hypotheses uh
would you agree that that that's a very
different style of of
experimental uh of the use of
experiments and that it it's uh it's a
much more focused kind of thing than
than the the approach that that you
outlined or or do am I missing something
are they actually the same thing I I I
think they are uh so I I I I I think uh
yes
the I I agree with you that hypothesis
you know they they there are all you
know a considerable part of the
experiments are used to validate uh
hypothesis to prove hypothesis and and
you know there are considerable amount
of experimental design is to uh with the
uh focus of proving hypothesis um I
think what I talked about here is an
approach to u to to actually do
exploration to to see what may be
possible hypothesis uh to prove uh but
the second part is also very important
um I agree with you that okay great
thanks are two types of
yeah okay any other
questions if now let's thank um our
great speaker today uh yes
shangu um and let's thank uh for the
wonderful talk thank you so much yes
yeah thank you thank you for your for
you know for inviting me and so yeah
well thank you for the wonderful talk
it's a interesting and exciting
topic all
right this ends the the web